did you only work with great people have
you for the most part have you ever
worked with those guys that guys gosh
yeah I mean I've been around oh yeah
I've been around a really long time
you're not that old and don't say that
you're not that much older than me but I
mean I've been working since I mean in
high school I did a thing with Amy and
the angel that Matthew Modine and Meg
Ryan were in when I was 17 years old so
it's been that an ABC after school
special do you remember what those were
lettering about come on SO aiming the
angel I played Amy and I was this it was
a remake of It's a Wonderful Life I was
a suicidal teenager and
Meg played one of the girls that was I
can't remember what her part one of the
high school girls in Matthew Modine
played like the angel I mean crazy we've
been around a long time wow but you've
seen some you've seen some actors
lose their you've seen some people
that are difficult to work with
and how do you deal with that
you know I've had a couple of
experiences in the last 10 years and I
won't name any names because I don't
want to do that but the hardest thing I
would say in the television world are
when actors show up and don't have their
lines down like at all
and I feel and I understand the family
pressures and the stresses but I really
think the stress it's so hard to make
these things the crew people working you
know one hour television there's just
nothing more brutal nothing 15-hour days
like and then the crew on top and that
thing of just you know if I could have a
magic wand it would be we all would have
better memories or be able to memorize
lines better because I think that really
does so you remember an incident or
incidents where you know someone didn't
know their lines at all and it was
holding everybody up and they they
didn't care I mean I just it's
it's maybe a way of working I would say
it's something that ages me or shows
that I'm from a different thing where
some people just could get the lines
just like that I mean one thing I really
don't want to keep working for is
because it is so hard to memorize now I
mean as I'm getting older it's just it's
a lot yeah and my my focus is so much on
writing the dissertation and being in
school and then you're just gonna mowed
into this interior world of acting
enlightenment